le nombre de contaminations et de décès
liés à la comique 19 est toujours élevé
en allemagne au cours des dernières 24
heures presque seize mille personnes ont
confirmé avoir le coronavirus avec 425
décès enregistrés dimanche soir ce sont
des chiffres particulièrement élevé pour
un week-end vendredi le triste record du
nombre de décès a été dépassé en
allemagne avec 1188 décès confirmés
merkel a tenu un discours solennel ce
week end incitant les allemands à
réfléchir à leur action et à leurs
conséquences pour leurs concitoyens les
mesures de confinement introduite avant
la période de fin d'année ont été
prolongées et renforcer la semaine
dernière elles resteront en place
jusqu'à la fin janvier et seront
réévaluées le 25
cependant il est probable qu'elles
seront encore prolongée des bars et
restaurants ne peuvent plus accueillir
de clients
les commerces de détail non essentiels
sont fermés ainsi que les coiffeurs les
écoles et les maternelles ont également
été mis en place pour les passagers
arrivant d'irlande suite à la flambée de
la mutation de coronavirus au royaume
uni à des vols provenant du royaume uni
étaient déjà soumis à des restrictions
il semble qu'elles seront étendues aux
vols en provenance de l'irlande et
galles
s'agissant du vaccin angela merkel a
promis d'accélérer le programme de
l'oxydation et d'autres nations
européennes a été critiqué pour la
lenteur de déploiement du vaccin
de la santé a déclaré à berlin qu'il
était satisfait du rythme de la
vaccination qu'ils avaient prioriser les
résidents des centres de soins avant
d'ouvrir le programme à l'ensemble de la
population propre la chaîne selon un
porte parole du gouvernement angela
merkel s'est entretenue avec le
président russe vladimir poutine à
propos d'une éventuelle production du
vaccin russe spoutnik vais en allemagne
le vaccin devrait d'abord être validée
par l'agencé européenne du médicament
ceux qui luttent pas encore le cas mais
le cas échéant le vaccin pourrait bien
être produits en allemagne aussi bien
qu'aux